support for think fast talk smart the
podcast comes in part from stanford
continuing studies
stanford continuing studies is offering
more than 140 online courses this spring
to enhance your personal and
professional life
choose from courses in business
leadership communication
tech and data science and many more
think fast talk smart listeners are
eligible for a 15 tuition discount when
using the code
think 15.
this promotion is available for the
spring quarter only registration is now
open classes begin soon learn more at
continuing studies studies.stanford.edu
way back in graduate school i had an
amazing internship at george lucas's
lucas film
the ceo at the time once talked to us
about how hard it was to reliably and
predictably be creative
these concepts are often antithetical to
each other and they apply across
different industries
today we will explore how design
thinking can help with this challenge
i'm matt abrahams and i teach strategic
communication at stanford graduate
school of business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
i am super excited today to speak with
sarah stein greenberg who is the
executive director of the hasso plattner
institute of design at stanford
university known more simply as the
d-school
while leading this incredibly talented
and creative organization sarah found
time to author an awesome book called
creative acts for curious people how to
think create and lead in unconventional
ways
welcome sarah thanks for joining me i am
so excited for our conversation today
matt thank you so much i'm excited to be
here and if you could see my face right
now you'd see i have a huge smile on it
because i'm very excited for our
conversation well i've got a big smile
too so let's get started the d school is
all about helping students and
executives learn design thinking skills
for those who aren't familiar with
design thinking can you define what it
is and how it can help us personally as
well as professionally
i'm happy to start there
so many people have this idea of design
that is really about the kind of visual
aspects of the world around us like the
aesthetic qualities or maybe the way
that your room feels after you rearrange
the furniture right and those are
definitely aspects of design
and design has through its long history
really been kind of poking its nose into
lots of different places and what i mean
by that is those same ways that you can
think about being intentional about what
your room feels like or how your phone
is designed the way in which you know a
glass fits in your hand perfectly
those same ideas can actually be
extrapolated and used to design
experiences and services and even
systems and so we're in an era now where
design is being used not just for all of
those aesthetic purposes but also to
think about what should be created how
do we actually deliver services that are
better for the people who are accessing
them or less expensive thinking about
you know how do we actually like
redesign a complex system for example
one of our fellows a few years ago was
working on redesigning the way in which
substitute teaching happens in the
united states like really interesting
complex multivariable kinds of projects
and problems and so design thinking
is kind of the vocabulary that sits
underneath that right it's a way that
people who may have a formal design
training or may come from lots of
different disciplines
can start to use the same sets of
practices both the skills and the
mindsets of design to improve those
services improve those products and even
think really creatively about like what
the future of your business could look
like or how you might tackle a large
social system
wow it sounds like the design thinking
principles can be applied to so many
different processes and systems
and in what you just described it really
underlies that there's a science to it
it's creative and it's artful but
there's also a science to it and it i
personally have been exposed to it and
find it fascinating for how we can
design experiences for people so thank
you for sharing that
we recently spoke with gsb professor
chip heath about the curse of knowledge
knowing too much about what we do and
share and how it can lead to
miscommunication and a lack of
connection with those that we're
communicating with
your focus in your book on widening our
lens strikes me as a way to combat that
curse of knowledge and be more creative
and relevant at the same time can you
tell us a bit more about what you mean
by widening our lens and and how can we
actually do that
sure you know widening your lens i i use
that framing just because as somebody
who's a photographer i think a lot about
how your perspective is really altered
by not just the equipment that you're
using but let you know where you're
standing in relation to the subject or
the scene that you're trying to capture
and
in design you want to have a strong
point of view about what you're making
you want to understand the needs you
want to understand the context and then
you want to say like well i think that
it's going to work best if and then you
you really establish that strong point
of view some of those foundational
principles
but one of the things you have to
recognize is that you don't have the
view you have a point of view right
right and really understanding like well
how is someone else going to experience
this product or service that i'm
developing or what if i think about what
the effect of launching this thing might
be a few generations into the future and
so there are all different ways to
stretch your perspective both to be
thinking about how could this be better
designed how could it be more effective
how could it be more relevant for more
people and even thinking about what are
some of the potentially unintended
consequences that could happen as i
create this you know fantastic popular
successful piece of work whatever it is
that you're doing
so widening your lens is one of those
core ideas in human-centered design in
that you're
very often you are not designing for
yourself yeah and you kind of have to
get out of your own way to effectively
design with others needs in mind and so
that idea of shifting your perspective
widening your aperture or your lens is
just critically important
and there are lots of ways to do that
and some of the practices in creative
acts are great ways to start there are
practices around you know how do you
have a very open-ended interview
interaction how do you try to
shadow someone for a day i heard you say
two things that i think are absolutely
critical to
getting out of that curse of knowledge
and how design thinking and being
creative can help and one is
understanding that it is other focused
you talked about human-centered design
so it's not you're not designing for
yourself you're designing for others
when you communicate you're not
communicating for yourself you're
communicating for others so first taking
that perspective and then the second
thing you said which is so important is
to get out of your own way that we
actually make it more difficult for
ourselves and it sounds like some of the
activities in your book and that are
practiced at the d school can really
help people with both parts of that
focusing in the right place and then
getting out of our own way did i get
that right
yeah that's exactly right and you know
we all bring our own life experience our
own biases our own opinions and
perspectives and so you often need a way
to to you know similar to how we talk
about deferring judgment when you're
trying to generate new ideas you
actually need to set aside those
assumptions that you have those biases
those perspectives that you have to make
sure they are not too influential
in your interpretation of or
understanding of what the needs are
as i think about what we've talked about
so far part of the design process really
involves introspection and reflection
i'm curious if you can articulate why
this is so important and what are some
of the specific tools and techniques
that you recommend to help people do
this type of self-learning
well it's interesting that you just
framed up this idea of self-learning
because i often think about design as a
process of learning
in general
so you know when you're starting out to
design something new whether it's
reimagining the substitute teaching
ecosystem like i mentioned our former
fellow jill violet did or something much
more concrete and physical you're
embarking on a journey of learning right
you are starting out with less
understanding and information and
insight and fewer ideas about where
you're gonna land the thing that you're
gonna create then you will ultimately
find yourself with
and
just like any other learning process
understanding what's going well and
what's not going well and what could be
improved
that is a vital part of really having
ownership over
that process
so we do a lot of work with our students
and other learners around tools for
reflection thinking about you know what
just happened and was it as productive
as effective as powerful as we hoped
that it was
what could be improved and maybe even
then some bigger picture questions so
i'll give you two examples of particular
practices that we use so one is an
individual practice which is called what
so what now what
leticia britos cavanaugh and some of her
colleagues created
and what they found is that when they
ask students to just kind of generically
reflect in an open-ended way on how
class went or what they learned or you
know what a particular process let's say
they were teaching prototyping that day
okay how did that go the students come
up with some interesting things but when
they give them a particular framework
like what so what now what which is
simply the idea that you separate you
disaggregate and distinguish between
those three different buckets so what
just happened name all the details what
did it smell like what was the feeling
that you had specifically what happened
and then so what which is like well what
were the implications what did that lead
to what happened as a result
and now what which is like well what
does that mean what does that suggest
for the future how do you feel about
that
those bigger introspective questions
with that particular rubric
the reflections that the students do are
of much higher caliber and much more
powerful as a learning tool as a
self-learning tool as you just said so
that's one great example of a practice
on the personal level
and then one of my favorites from this
collection is called i like i wish how
to
and that is a practice that we've been
using at the d school from the very
beginning
and it really is wonderful as a group to
go through an experience together that
could be a day of class that could be a
workshop that could be a tough year at
your company
and do a group reflection
using those prompts i like i wish and
how to
and that is a non-judgmental or less
judgmental way to still be able to say
like hey here's what went well here's
what i wish for
and here are some other ideas that are
starting to come up about what we could
do to to change things or improve things
well i think we have bingo now because
anybody who knows me and listens to this
podcast knows that what so what now what
is a mantra that i sing the praises for
all the time and and i love how you
apply it in terms of self learning in
terms of feedback and introspection
and having tools as you've discussed to
help us do that is really really helpful
because for many of us it's really hard
to take the time to do that reflection
and having specific tools
can help
in thinking back to all of the various
activities and techniques in your book
can you identify one that has really
helped you personally
yeah you know i i mentioned i like i
wish which has been quite important for
me the category that i'll share that i
think has been really useful for me
particularly in a leadership role to
remember to practice consistently
is around
using those first few minutes of any
meeting or work session to set the right
tone and to get people already starting
to practice some of the behaviors that
you want to see come out in the work to
be done through some kind of warm-up
activity
and i have kind of a strong point of
view that like icebreakers are fine but
usually what i'm doing is not trying to
just get people to break the ice and
know each other a little bit i'm
actually wanting people to start to
rehearse the same behavior that we need
to then practice as a group so
the activities that are around building
trust with someone that's a wonderful
warm-up to do if you're gonna have a
group then start to launch an
interviewing process or even if you're
just gonna try to make a hard decision
right that's a really good time to use
that as a team
or the activity that's around coming up
with lots of metaphors and similes for
complex problems or topics that is a
great warm-up to use when you are
launching a storytelling session or you
are trying to figure out how are you
going to present your really cool but
kind of esoteric new idea to a group of
people so i like to really match
the nature of the warm-up with the work
at hand and if i'm the one who's leading
the class or the workshop i'll then be
very transparent for folks hey the
reason we started with this is because
it's going to lead right into what we're
doing today as a group and i find that
that helps people get like right into
the right mindset and the right kind of
skill set for the work at hand
i find that so
refreshing because so many people do ice
breakers just for the sake of doing an
icebreaker in this notion that the
activity you initiate with can actually
serve as
a
signpost for what's to come or get
people to rehearse and practice skills
that you'll be developing i think is
really powerful and i encourage
everybody to think about when you
initiate a meeting a presentation any
kind of collaboration how can you start
with some kind of activity that gets
people focused and engaged but also
begins working on the skills you're
trying to build i really like that idea
and will immediately begin applying it
in the work i do
before we end i'd like to ask you the
same three questions i ask everyone who
joins me are you up for that
yes excellent all right here we go
question one if you were to capture the
best communication advice you ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title
what would it be
what comes to mind
is just a slide that says pause more
ooh
tell me more about that i'm going to
take a pause before you answer though
okay go ahead tell me more i love
talking about this topic i love talking
about this material when i get excited
about something i just get on a roll
and often string things together that
deserve more breathing room
and
as a communicator i am working on trying
to slow down
and pause more
right silence is such a powerful tool in
multiple dimensions whether it's giving
someone else the chance for their brain
to catch up whether it's for you to slow
down and then be able to observe new
things and take in detail in a way that
you weren't previously
so i think that my excitement and
enthusiasm sometimes just revs up the
speed and the pace at which i'm talking
and
really just slowing down and pausing
occasionally it can be so helpful
not only does it help you think and
formulate but it also helps the audience
as well and i am in your camp when i get
excited i i talk more than less
let me ask question number two
who is a communicator that you admire
and why
the first person who jumps to mind right
now is phoebe robinson who's a comedian
and a
tv host and she's now
running a book imprint publishing
imprint
i feel like she just has this incredible
facility with language
and she's constantly inventing words and
yet you completely understand what she's
saying and somehow it's like so much
funnier because it's in this sort of
like language of her own invention and
it's really
body and satirical and it's just just
very very funny and i suspect that she
is making so many specific decisions
about her language choice and her
created words and i i'd love to just get
a peek inside her brain and understand
more about how she thinks about these
things
what a true compliment when you want to
really understand somebody's thought
process that leads them to their
communication
let me ask the final question what are
the first three ingredients that go into
a successful communication recipe
maybe the most important ingredient is
caring about the topic
i think the second one for me is about
distilling
the content into its barest form
and then for me i'm often communicating
in a visual medium as are so many people
so i think i immediately just left to
like thinking about designing a keynote
or a powerpoint presentation which
so many people have we've as a human
race we have wasted so much time trying
to read
size eight font on uh
it's like it's just so sad so
when i'm thinking about
using visuals to amplify the
presentation i'm giving or the ideas i'm
trying to share
i think about what i'm excited about my
passion or commitment to the material i
mean and this is true even if i'm giving
like a budget report
in the dean's office i'm like i want to
see some student faces on that i want to
always be reminded of the purpose behind
the work that we're doing
and then think about the simplest form
that i can use and the fewest words and
how much of it can become visual
so let me go back and try to boil that
down into three
three simple ingredients i think it's
about interest and passion for the
content
simplicity
and
bringing things to life in a visual way
i think those are three very powerful
ingredients and can be very helpful for
all the types of communication that we
do
well sarah i have to thank you so much
your ideas are super practical super
helpful and really really fun i've
enjoyed our conversation i appreciate
your insights in the design creativity
and communication and i encourage
everyone to get sarah's book creative
acts for curious people and then you
have to immediately read it and apply
these incredibly useful lessons and
activities thank you for joining us and
thank you for sharing
my pleasure thank you so much for having
me matt
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
produced by stanford university's
graduate school of business
for more information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu
or subscribe to our show wherever you
get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
stanford.gsb